look at this rate is to threats the  future stability of our country is  either a label SMP alive or a  right-winger yarn so Luca balance  between the Conservative Party and Nigel  Farage buddy you pictures Oh  nevertheless it either you put boats  awful effective anything over the last  couple of weeks it's hardened whilst SNP  support might put mr miliband in number  ten that payback for labor will be very  costly indeed David Cameron is setting  one part of the United Kingdom against  another and I think that is dangerous  he's talking up the SNP's chances and I  think that is dangerous dr. scenario all  the sign of the desperation going  desperation of a Tory party that's  starting to face up to the fact that it  may well lose this election the general  election is getting closer and closer  and there's just over two weeks to go  now to decide what the future of our  country looks like I'm big enough and  I've made after make my decision since  I've